good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 21 19 one object
class Keter formally Euclid special
containment procedures the foundation is
to maintain surveillance operations but
as otherwise not to directly interfere
with SCP twenty-one 91 or the ritual
practices of communities within the
vicinity of the Jolla forest exploration
of SCP 21 19 is prohibited outside of
remotely controlled drones foundation
operatives are to maintain the facade of
forest rangers in the employ of the
Romanian government in the event of a
SCP 21 19 one security breach by
civilians or hostile entities lethal
force is authorized
[Music]
description SCP 21 19 is a temple
complex located within the dense Jolla
forest of Romania the first two floors
of the structure hold a close
resemblance to Eastern Orthodox
monasteries commonly found in the region
this is suspected to have being a
deliberate effort to disguise the true
nature of SCP 21 19 Racine and Dassey in
architecture have both been discovered
in the lower levels of the temple
complex and artifacts belonging to the q
key 10 e triple Ian culture have been
recovered from the system of tunnels
that makes up the lowest known portion
of SCP 21 19 the caverns of SCP 21 19 1
are not thought to have formed naturally
and were likely constructed circa 4,800
to 3000 BC SCP 2191 is inhabited by a
population of organisms classified as
SCP 21 19 1 - one instances of scp-2107
durg on several significant seemingly
fatal mutations SCP 21 19 1 - 1 lakh
all major internal organs with the
exception of lungs heart and brain stem
the outer epidermis lacks pigmentation
and displays a condition resembling
cracked porcelain possibly related to
Harlequin syndrome entities appear
androgynous lacking or having somehow
removed secondary sex characteristics
they're regressed eyes are covered by a
layer of skin rendering them mostly
blind but still able to react to light
universally displaying a version two
wavelengths of greater than 100
nanometers further deviations from
baseline Homo sapiens include especially
flat upturned noses and funnel shaped
ears both considered related to their
dependency on olfactory and auditory
perception SCP 21 19 1 - 1 do not appear
to communicate via language they only
sound produced being a persistent
clicking of the tongue speculated to be
a form of echolocation SCP 21 19 1 do
not readily appear to undergo senescence
and have not aged since containment
further analysis has revealed that
abnormally slow metabolism SCP 2191 -
one instances are not believed to be
biologically immortal but have a
significantly decreased rate of necrosis
SCP 21 19 1 - - refers to a collective
of vermiform organisms these organisms
vary in size form and purpose and are
accordingly classified SCP 2191 2a 2b
and 2c genetic analysis of SCP 21 19 1 -
to show close relation with fellow
subgroups their most recent common
ancestors being Homo sapiens it has been
speculated that SCP 21 19 1 - - did not
naturally evolve in their own but their
true origin remains unknown SCP 2191 2a
superficially resemble pet Romasanta
forms lamprey but whose internal
structure more closely resemble here
edenian leeches
each SCP twenty-one 90
one - one has a SCP 21 19 1 - to a
instance within their abdomen primarily
located where the stomach and large
intestines would exist SCP 2191 to be
are an infestation of vermin form
organisms that live throughout the
hollow walls of SCP 21 19 1 as CP 2191
appears to have been constructed with a
system of channels through which SCP 21
19 1 to be travel these thin long
organisms will enter a CP 2191 - one
orifices primarily via the mouth or
rectum but do not appear to cause harm
or discomfort to their hosts SCP 21 19 1
to be are believed to redistribute
nutrients throughout SCP 21 19 extracted
from any SCP 21 19 1 - 1 which have
recently fent
SCP 21 19 1 to see like to be inhabit
the interior architecture of SCP 21 19
these tendril like appendages are
composed primarily of neurons and
attached to SCP 21 19 1 - one at the
base of the spine while inactive only
when attached to SCP 21 19 1 to C do SCP
21 19 1 - 1 display behavior resembling
that of a sapient organism including
posturing suggestive of Prayer SCP 2191
- 1 are considered inactive while
connected to SCP 21 19 1 to see during
an active state SCP 2190 1 - 1 entities
will leave SCP twenty-one 91 an
aggressively hunt for living humans
ignoring non-human animals and deceased
individuals active states do not occur
simultaneously among SCP 2191 - 1
although an active state will always
occur between dusk and dawn nor do they
hunt as a pack choosing to spread
throughout the forest a paralytic agent
is employed to disable their prey
injected via venom delivering Barb's
located in
lower carpals of both hands when pray
have been successfully incapacitated SE
p 21 91 - one will open its mouth and
widen its throat unhinging its jaw in
the process as CP 21 91 - to a will then
emerge from a CP 2191 - one's interior
cavity initiating the feeding process by
latching to the victim's neck by a
toothed funnel like sucking mouth SCP
2191
- a will first inject the body with
digestive enzymes liquid izing organ
muscle and bone alike before consuming
the result of fluids this process can
last anywhere from 20 to 50 minutes
depending on the size of the prey
although known to those living in the
vicinity of the Jolla forest SCP 21 19 1
was not recognized by the foundation as
an anomaly until august 1916 after the
unexplained disappearance of 244 members
of the austro-hungarians first army
during the battle of transylvania due to
the first world war operations to
contain the threat did not begin until
early 1919 without a source of food SCP
2191 - one entities appeared to enter a
dormant state as of December 1924
several incidents occurring between 1932
and 1977 would result in the discovery
of SCP 21 19 1 - 3 26th of September
1932 grease the are' sauce earthquake
devastates the Halkidiki Peninsula and
results in 491 reported casualties 126
individuals were unaccounted for but the
event was ultimately deemed
non-anomalous a connection to SCP 21 19
1 established years later
December 26 1939 turkey near zinc and
earthquake results in the deaths of
approximately 33,000 people locals
report a Great Serpent rising from the
ground at the onset of the earthquake
the foundation begins to investigate the
region
November 10th 1940 Romania an earthquake
strikes verencia casualties are low
civilians report vampire attacks in wake
of the disaster media outlets publicly
dismissing the claim as superstition
March 18th 1953 turkey the yen is gone
an earthquake causes widespread damage
killing over a thousand people several
survivors report seeing the arm of an
octopus rupture from the earth civilians
report pale men attacking survivors in
the night reports ceasing after
approximately one month after the
disaster July 26th 1963 Macedonia the
Skopje earthquake kills over 1,000
people and renders 200,000 homeless
approximately 500 would go missing in
wake of the disaster reports of pale men
in the night are common March 4th 1977
Romania the Vrancea earthquake kills
over 1,500 however only 800 bodies are
accounted for reports of pale men and
tendrils pulling victims beneath the
ground panic spreads throughout the
region foundation operatives are able to
confirm a connection to SCP 2191
SCP 2190 1-3 is an organism whose core
is located deep beneath SC p21 91 it's
true size has proven difficult if not
entirely impossible to measure but root
like appendages extend throughout an
area of approximately six hundred and
sixty thousand square kilometers SCP
2190 1-3 secretes a highly corrosive
substance which is employed in the
creation of tunnels throughout the
Balkan Peninsula SCP 21 19 1 - 3 is
sapient and exerts control over SCP 2191
- 1 an SCP 2191 - two organisms by a
physical interaction with SCP 21 19 1 -
to see and through the release of
complex pheromones SCP 21 19 1-1
entities through the use of SCP 21 19 1
2 a to be act as feeder drones for SCP
21 19 1 - 3 in has since been discovered
that civilians native to several
isolated villages in vicinity of Joya
forest have actively provided human
sacrifices to SCP 21 19 1 as a means of
minimizing seismic activity this is
interview 1977 playing log now
interviewer dr. jewel of forward dragon
egg rescue is a village elder and
midwife 96 years of age she has proven
knowledgeable with regards to the
folklore and traditions associated with
her CP 2191
and claims to be a descendant of the
solomon are what do you tell me about
the temple
[Music]
[Music]
and this is a statement from the o-5
council so listen up
there are some who wish to believe that
the foundation has never nor will ever
cater to the designs and desires of an
anomalous entity Foundation efforts do
contain a CP 2191 are now thought to
have inadvertently led to the deaths of
approximately 40,000 over 45 years the
obvious choice would be to neutralize
the threat and we've tried the number of
civilian and foundation casualties being
well beyond acceptable numbers in order
to contain the larger threat we must
allow it to feed we are aware of the
offence caused by this procedure this is
not the first time nor will it be the
last that the foundation has been forced
to commit a and lesser evil in
prevention of a greater we do believe
that in the end our current method is
the most preferable with regards to both
ethics and efficiency we are aware that
every sacrifice feeds SCP 21 19 1-3
allowing it and its brood to thrive but
we are not about to sacrifice the entire
balkan peninsula to neutralize that
threat not yet well there you go it's
not often you get to hear from an o-5
huh wonder which one it was yeah that'll
be your homeworks that'll be fun
actually you know what never mind
I want to deal with you guys any more
than I have to okay thank you very much
for listening if indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim Mookie slump
God dr. day John Oh quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator neck tie verbal Kody
tench
cheese whip I'm Depp's McGee thank you
all so much for your support
I really appreciate it if you would like
a special thank you at the end of each
of my videos on some other cool stuff as
well as at patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
[Music]
you